hey this is presh talwalkar
this puzzle was sent to me by email
hi presh
this problem is so up your alley and i
am requesting a video on it
take any equilateral triangle and pick a
random point inside the triangle
draw from each vertex a line to the
random point
two of the three angles at the random
point are known let's say angles x and y
if the three line segments from each
vertex to the random point were removed
out of the original triangle to form a
new triangle
what would the new triangle's angles be
try to figure it out i was unable to do
so
but i do have the unbelievable solution
if you have any trouble regards daniel e
now i will say i did give this problem
an honest effort and i was stumped
please help me solve this problem
daniel then provided me with the
solution
this problem also has an interesting
background
there's a lot more about it in the video
simple math problems to fool the best on
the youtube channel gold-plated goof
the problem is also part of a collection
of quote killer problems
that were very easy to state
and almost impossible to solve unless
you knew a very specific trick
and as such these problems could be used
for discriminatory purposes at
universities
so please check out these sources for
more about the historical background
about this problem and other problems in
this video i'm just going to focus on
the problem and show you the solution
so can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
so preliminary to get started
is that the lengths of the three sides
uniquely define a triangle by the side
side side postulate
so we just need to find any triangle
with the three sides blue yellow and
purple and then solve for its angles
so how do we do that
it seems pretty impossible how can we
get from this triangle's angles to the
original angles
well let me present to you the ingenious
trick
the problem becomes easy
if you rotate the triangle 60 degrees
from a vertex
so let's imagine rotating this triangle
60 degrees counterclockwise from the
bottom left vertex
we now
connect the random point on the rotated
triangle to the original triangle
and we will show
that we have now found a triangle
with a blue yellow and purple side
so this will be the triangle
and we will be able to solve for its
angles
so that's going to be the plan of the
proof
now how do we know this is the
particular triangle we're looking for so
let's work each step out
the first step is that the two blue
lines form a 60 degree angle
this is because the triangle was rotated
60 degrees
but just to be sure we know this is a 60
degree angle let's figure it out
suppose the blue segment divided the
equilateral triangle into angles a
and 60 minus a
we'll mark the same angles in the
triangle that was rotated
now
the two blue lines make an angle of 60
minus a plus a which is 60 degrees
so we've proved that this angle between
the two blue lines is 60 degrees
next
we'll show that the blue lines define an
equilateral triangle
we'll form a triangle by connecting the
endpoints of the two blue line segments
the two blue line segments have the same
length
therefore we have an isosceles triangle
with the vertex angle of 60 degrees
the remaining two angles will be equal
to each other and the sum of the three
angles in a triangle is 180 degrees
so each remaining angle will be 180
minus 60
and then we divide that by two so each
remaining angle is 60 degrees
therefore all three angles of this
triangle are 60 degrees
and so it's an equilateral triangle
so the very last side has the same
length as the blue sides so i'll color
this last side in blue
now what can we do from here
we now have the triangle that we're
looking for with a blue yellow and
purple side
so we'll solve for the angles of this
triangle
the first thing we can do is we can
solve that the angle between the purple
and blue sides is x minus 60 degrees
next we'll solve for the angle between
the yellow and the blue side
this can be done because
in the original triangle this angle is y
when we rotate the triangle
we know that the corresponding angle
will be y
and the angle that we're looking for
will be y minus 60.
so we figured out two of the angles in
this triangle
and we only have one more angle to
figure out
so how can we figure out this final
angle
well the sum of the angles in a triangle
is 180 degrees so the final angle will
be 180 degrees minus each of the two
angles we know
x minus 60 and y minus 60.
so this will result in the angle of 300
minus x minus y
and that's the ingenious solution to
this seemingly impossible problem
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description
you can support me on patreon and you
can also catch me on social media either
at mindyourdecisions or at presh
tallwalker